three and a half minutes the equalizer
in the equalizer denzel washington plays
one of those really cool guys that you
like to work with you know he's really
positive everyone loves him he works at
this Home Depot ish hardware store he
works hard he pays his taxes he has a
routine to his life so you know he's
this methodical badass you know he can
end lives well if he needs to then Chloe
grace Moretz gets her ass kicked like
pretty ICU as she knows she was in
pretty bad shape
he's his nice guy and you know he gonna
be friended her you know she goes to the
same diner he goes to and he's like all
right got a decision to make and like
our other older badass before him he has
a particular set of skills and now he's
gonna exercise that so now it's denzel
versus the russian mob there you go I'm
not gonna lie to you the equalizers are
pretty straightforward movie there's
gonna be a pretty straightforward review
this is the Denzel show and Denzel is a
badass he's just really fun to watch I
like rules like this played by actors
like this he's awesome he's likable you
know if you tell this guy your secrets
he's not gonna tell anybody and in the
end if you're a friend of his and
someone messes with you he will mess
their up which is a convenience for
this movie this guy's lived a pretty
low-key life and in the course of one
week people just start messing with
people in his life and then he just
starts taking them out yeah you got the
chloë grace moretz thing with the mob
and then someone does arson to one of
his friends places and then someone else
gets robbed all this on the course of
what a couple days never before but now
that you've taken on the mob now all
this weird shits gonna trickle down as a
convenience for the movie and I
understand you need conveniences like
that to get a movie like this going
because the movie about a mild-mannered
guy who used to be a badass in life it
works at a hardware store now takes on
the Russian mob you need unbelievable
to get an unbelievable movie like
this flowing things like that take me
out of the movie for a second I'm like
that's alright whatever doesn't change
the fact that he's good in it it's just
fun to see him kick ass it really is
he's so good at it and so smart like
he's better than anybody could be at
this because it's Denzel it's that
guy there's nothing uncool about that
guy the villain in this movie you can
tell he's like a villain that you need
to see do bad to people for the
sake of knowing that Louie's a villain
but sometimes it's conflicting he's just
really calm collected methodical guys I
mean like beats a guy's ass pretty much
to death with his bare hands he's just
raging out on him you're like alright
I guess I'm not a psychopath maybe
that's what would happen the end of this
movie is it's a weird thing for me cuz
I'm kind of conflicted about it one part
I'm like oh that's cool and Denzel is
still a badass and he's taking dudes out
and that's really cool but it's also
home alone in home deep holy it's
home alone Depot that's what it is and
at a point I was like wow this scene is
still going it's the longest scene ever
it seems that way anyway the good part
is this movie knows what it is it knows
what it wants to do and it doesn't
there's no deeper meaning to this movie
it's not some period piece is not going
for an Oscar it may be fall but we're
not into Oscar bait season yet this
movie wanted to show a damaged
mild-mannered guy who's trying to live a
nice life have something terrible
happened to a friend of his and now he
just takes on everyone specifically the
Russian mob because everyone knows
Russian mobs bad if you want baddies and
people to believe that the really bad
people without them actually having to
do anything to prove it
Russian mob it was a Denzel show Denzel
was likable Denzel was a badass he did
badass and I was entertained by the
movie I will say the equalizer is a good
time no alcohol required funny thing
though this movie is directed by the
director of training day in this movie
Denzel Washington has a big problem with
the Russian mob in training day Denzel
Washington has a big problem with the
Russian mob maybe this is how it happens
it's like a training day prequel who
knew Alonzo Harris worked at a hardware
store he's like the nice guy dancing in
he was all awesome people loved
Alonzo Harris back been three and a half
minutes so the equalizer have you seen
it what did you think about it but every
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you liked what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more